well the crash was filmed by one of the
spectators and ended Brady's report
contains images of the immediate
aftermath of that crash the Reno Air
Races attract thousands of people every
September to watch some of America's
most talented pilots compete against
each other this amateur footage was
filmed from a packed grandstand as a
vintage aircraft known as the galloping
Goulston slammed into the VIP area
eyewitnesses said the plane was about
400 feet in the air when it's suddenly
nosedived
just twisted and turned and Wham and it
was all brown smoke and debris no fire
is sort of wobbling and then it came up
and he started heading towards the
stands and looked like he was going to
try and if he was still controlling he
was going to try and fly over the stands
to just get away from those and that the
plane just kind of turned hard and when
it started coming down it looked like he
must have been pulling really hard on
the stick to try and get as far away
from the stands as possible renowned
ston pilot Jimmy Lee word was killed in
the crash he'd flown in more than a
hundred and twenty races since the 1970s
and had worked on numerous movies most
of his family were there to watch him
fly the injured were taken to a nearby
hospital in Reno some of the more
seriously hurt were flown there by
helicopter this tragedy and we are doing
everything we can to move along and
communicate work with the folks that are
directly and adversely affected by this
four pilots were killed here between
2007 and 2008 prompting local school
officials to consider whether or not to
ban student field trips to the event
organizers have now cancelled the rest
of the air races as investigators begin
the task of piecing together what went
so badly wrong
you